des victoires des défaites des records
des stars l'année 2016 a été riche en
événements sportifs dans les yvelines au
mois d'avril élan courtois d'ilham
houmadi champion d'europe des poids
super-moyens depuis 2015 s'est incliné
contre le britannique adam smith
contrées dès le premier run le sportif a
été mis ko et a dû abandonner sa
ceinture à 36 ans le mois de juin lui
était traversé par un vent de fraîcheur
venus de toute l'europe les footballeurs
irlandais russes ont établi leur camp de
base à versailles à croissy sur seine
pendant l'euro les supporters ont pu les
approcher
alors comme on disait à quand on disait
ça fait du bien de voir une autre équipe
jouer que que l'équipe de france ça
serait je suis habitué plus à aller voir
les joueurs de l'équipe de france jouer
donc là de voir l'équipe d'irlande
ça fait plaisir l'équipe de france qui
était-elle installé à clairefontaine a
finalement mis fin au rêve de victoire
des irlandais 8e de finale 2 à 1 pour
les bleus un autre britannique a marqué
cette année 2016 dans les yvelines rory
mcilroy numéro trois mondial a participé
à la 100e édition de l'open de france de
golf
la superstar nord-irlandaise n'a pu
faire mieux que troisième derrière
l'italien francesco molinari et tong
chaï 10 46 ans
ça a été difficile de mettre vos coups
de coeur disent les conditions n'étaient
pas excellentes pour le faire tong chaï
a joué de façon très impressionnante et
je pense que je n'avais aucune chance de
gagner un été olympique pour une dizaine
dit vinoy les athlètes ont remporté au
total onze médailles 3 en or 3 en argent
et 5 en bronze aux jo de rio symbole de
ce cru exceptionnel dans la délégation
heavy noise le boxeur tony hawk a
décroché l'or dans la catégorie super
lourd
thomas baruch licencié au cercle
nautique de versailles lui décroché le
bronze avec ses coéquipiers sur le
quatre sans barreur poids léger derrière
la suisse et le danemark
on avait la volonté on savait que
c'était possible qu'on avait le talent
et les capacités de le faire donc très
content d'y être
en septembre les cougars ont réussi à
remonter en première division après une
victoire arrachée sur leur terrain
contre les deux filles dogs de st juste
ils goûteront à nouveau aux joies de
l'élite après l'avoir quittée pendant
cinq ans ça a été une finale de folie
vraiment et nous sommes heureux qu'ils
aient réussi à obtenir
à voir leurs objectifs à atteindre leurs
objectifs moins de réussite pour
l'équipe de football américain des
templiers d'elancourt les saint
quentinois font le chemin inverse et
passe de la première à la deuxième
division après avoir terminé dernier du
championnat élite
en octobre les yvelines ont connu une
nouvelle compétition d'envergure
internationale avec les championnats
d'europe de cyclisme sur piste au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le trappistes
benjamin thomas 21 ans a brillé en
remportant une médaille d'or en
poursuite par équipes le bronze sur
l'omnium et l'argent sur l'américaine
j'habite à à cinq kilomètres du
vélodrome donc la piste on la connaît
par coeur on s'entraîne moi je
m'entraîne tout temps ici donc c'est
vrai que ça fait plaisir
ma famille qui étaient ici ma copine et
où donc c'est top
les événements également le pied marin
trois skippers giner du département se
sont inscrits pour participer à la 8e
édition du vendée globe
laurent blain louis burton et les
versaillais eric bio et tanguy de
lamotte se sont élancés pour ce tour du
monde en solitaire le 6 novembre une
balade une balade
sans rire quoi
comme ça ça doit faire plusieurs tonnes
ayant termine par une épopée historique
le club des clayes-sous-bois réussi à se
hisser au 6e tour de la coupe
gambardella la coupe de france des moins
de 19 ans et que les siens petit poucet
de l'épreuve sur ce tour ont été
éliminés par caen après un match
spectaculaire perdu 4 à 3 on est fiers
représente les plus boire ou on les a
représentés
on se connaît dans les cent soixante
quatre meilleures équipes de france
ans en championnat plus de 2000 rendez
vous en 2010 est pour de nouvelles
émotions sportives